...
-Claire Josserand-Schmidt, pour
les participants, le procès
des attentats du Bataclan
était le dossier d'une vie.
Avez-vous, vous aussi,
eu le sentiment
que ce procès
était historique ?
-Je m'en rends compte.
Maintenant.
Sur le moment,
je suis dans mon procès,
je vis mon procès à 100 %.
Je suis tellement
concentrée sur ma tâche,
que je n'en prends pas
encore la mesure,
mais maintenant
qu'on en est sortis
et que je vois
avec quelles difficultés on en sort,
même nous, les professionnels,
je me rends compte
avec le recul
qu'on a vécu un procès
absolument incroyable.
-On voit là une planche
de Charlie Hebdo,
dans un hors-série.
A plus d'un titre, ce procès
était hors normes
de par son envergure,
sa démesure,
sa longueur,
le nombre de victimes,
sa charge émotionnelle,
et bien sûr symbolique,
son décorum, aussi...
Peut-on dire qu'il a
été conforme au droit
et à ce qu'on pouvait
en attendre ?
-Alors,
j'ai réfléchi, beaucoup, mais pas
seulement au stade de l'audience.
Le terrorisme, c'est vraiment
une matière qui nous plonge tous
dans notre effroi,
dans notre émotion
la plus profonde.
Effectivement,
le respect de la norme,
du début à la fin,
pose question.
Depuis la récolte
des preuves...
On a parlé durant le procès,
notamment, des preuves de guerre,
qui doivent normalement répondre
à des conditions de récolte...
Jusqu'à l'exécution des peines.
Est-ce que l'exécution des peines,
en détention, le parcours
des accusés se fait-il
de la même façon ?
En termes d'application
des peines
et de temps long,
les choses se passent-elles
de la même façon ?
La question s'est posée.
Je suis avocate victime,
mais je vais répondre
avec la plus grande
sincérité,
parce que même quand
on défend des victimes,
on se rend compte parfois,
qu'il y a des pas de côté.
On s'est rendu compte,
que dans ce procès, on était
sortis de la route habituelle.
C'est dû à une chose,
c'est aux critères quantitatifs.
-C'est-à-dire ?
-Les victimes
étaient tellement nombreuses.
Elles sont si nombreuses...
-1500 parties civiles.
-...que le procès s'étire sur
une longueur complètement inédite.
Nécessairement,
l'organisation des débats
se fait de façon
différente.
En fait, c'est tout simple.
Si, après une attaque terroriste,
les victimes
se chiffrent
en dizaines,
il y a un équilibre
entre le boxe...
-Le boxe des accusés.
-...et les parties civiles.
-Là, il y a un déséquilibre.
-S'il y a 2000 parties civiles,
3000 parties civiles,
que nous sommes
actuellement,
dans Nice,
130 avocats constitués,
pour les attentats
du 13 novembre 2015,
on était prêt de 300,
nécessairement,
il y a un déséquilibre,
qui ne peut pas jouer en faveur
de la défense des accusés...
Nécessairement.
-Vous vous êtes illustrée,
lors du procès,
comme celle grâce à qui
Salah Abdeslam a parlé.
C'était le moment
le plus attendu du procès.
Personne n'y croyait.
C'est à vous et grâce à vous
qu'il a expliqué
avoir renoncé
à se faire exploser.
Comment avez-vous trouvé le ton
et les mots justes pour briser
son mur du silence ?
Avez-vous fait
psychologie 1e langue ?
Elles rient.
-Déjà, je voudrais associer
ma consoeur Aurélie Cerceau.
C'est une consoeur avec laquelle
j'ai travaillé tout ce procès.
On a parlé toutes les deux
avec Salah Abdeslam,
même au cours
des suspensions
d'audience.
On n'a pas fait de magie,
c'est pas 8 ans d'audience.
On lui a parlé normalement,
on l'a rejoint sur
un terrain humain,
je pense qu'il l'a senti.
-Vous étiez avocate
des parties civiles.
-Oui, mais...
-Vous avez continué.
-Oui, mais si vous voulez,
je pense que les débats
judiciaires, leur vertu,
pour moi, c'est de créer
une sorte de no man's land,
une sorte de zone,
entre le boxe et les bancs
des parties civiles,
dans laquelle on va
pouvoir apprendre
l'un de l'autre.
Je suis convaincue
que l'on peut apprendre d'eux,
et apporter beaucoup aux victimes
qu'on représente en allant chercher,
en comprenant
le pourquoi du comment,
en saisissant
ce point de bascule
qui va les amener
finalement
à adhérer à l'idéologie de l'Etat
islamique.
Je suis persuadée
également à l'inverse
que les accusés ont des choses
à apprendre des victimes.
On l'a vu, du reste, à l'audience.
Je me souviens d'un moment
d'audience très fort...
Une mère qui a perdu sa fille
vient à la barre
et parle de tous
ces accusés,
en disant
qu'elle aurait
pu être leur mère,
les tenir dans ses bras.
Elle crée en plus un lien
avec eux de mère.
Il y en a un qui a réagi,
Sofiane Ayari.
Ca a déclenché quelque chose
chez lui et ça l'a amené
à accepter de se livrer
sur une partie
de son parcours.
Ca a pas été très long.
Il a pas non plus
tout raconté.
Il ne s'est pas livré
sur un épisode
qui aurait pu
impliquer les autres.
Et ses coaccusés.
Mais malgré tout,
je l'ai entendu parler,
raconter son histoire
en Syrie.
Des procès pour terrorisme,
j'en ai fait avant,
j'avais jamais entendu ça.
Ca n'est dû
qu'à quelque chose
qui s'est passé,
avec cette mère.
Salah Abdeslam
était prêt à ça.
Je pense que ce garçon,
pour tout le monde,
il incarne le mal absolu.
C'est le seul survivant
des attentats,
mais malgré tout,
au-delà du caractère
inhumain de l'acte,
c'est un être humain.
Je suis convaincue
que ce garçon,
à un moment donné,
s'est trouvé sur une ligne de crète,
a basculé du mauvais côté.
J'avais besoin,
dans l'intérêt,
de mes clients,
Aurélie Cerceau avait besoin
dans l'intérêt de ses clients,
et il y a beaucoup
de parties civiles
qui n'étaient pas
nos clients,
qui avaient besoin
de savoir,
de comprendre,
de l'entendre.
On y arrive pas parce
qu'on fait 8 ans d'étude
mais car on lui parle
normalement...
-Sans qu'on comprenne
vraiment pourquoi,
le président de la cour d'assises
a coupé court à cet échange,
et donné la parole
à un autre avocat.
Salah Abdeslam s'est refermé.
Est-ce que c'est un regret ?
-Je...
Je veux pas
me faire l'avocate
de Salah Abdeslam.
Il a fait ce qu'il a fait
et il a été condamné.
Il sera condamné
très sévèrement.
Ce que j'ai regretté,
pendant ces semaines d'audience,
c'est qu'on ne l'a pas laissé dire
tout ce qu'il avait à dire,
et je pense
qu'il s'est braqué
à cause de cela.
Y a un droit fondamental
pour un accusé, pour moi,
c'est de dire ce qu'il veut,
ou de ne rien dire
s'il veut rien dire.
C'est de ne pas répondre.
Un accusé a droit de mentir.
On a à apprendre
des mensonges
d'un accusé !
On a à apprendre de sa version,
de son histoire.
Il me semble aussi que la politique
n'est pas suffisamment entrée
dans ce procès.
A chaque fois
que Salah Abdeslam
faisait l'éloge
de la cause djihadiste,
on avait tellement peur
que ce procès lui donne
une tribune,
qu'on l'a stoppé net.
Pour moi, c'est un regret,
qu'on l'ait stoppé.
J'ai eu le sentiment
à plusieurs endroits,
que dès qu'il commençait
à parler, on l'arrêtait,
car sa parole était inaudible,
et qu'il fallait,
d'une façon,
lisser...
-Le canaliser.
-Lisser la parole entendue
dans cette salle...
C'est mon interprétation.
Pas l'interprétation
de tous les confrères.
Certains confrères
de parties civiles
considèrent
que c'est un grand pervers
qui aurait choisi un peu
ses interlocuteurs.
Je ne l'ai pas ressenti.
-La journaliste
Sylvie Caster, qui n'a pas
raté un seul jour d'audience,
n'a pas caché
son irritation
face aux provocations répétées
et parfois ouvertement odieuses
de Salah Abdeslam.
Elle a vu dans son mépris
une forme d'obscénité.
"Il faut une patience d'ange,
un self control
"hors du commun pour
interroger Abdeslam,
"car il mettrait les nerfs
à un bloc de briques."
Seriez-vous un bonze ?
Elles rient.
-Pas du tout.
-Vous l'avez pas vécu comme ça ?
-Non.
Je me retrouve pas là-dedans.
C'est compliqué,
de répondre à cela.
Salah Abdeslam...
...incarne
tout ce qui oppose
l'Etat islamique
au système démocratique
et à notre Etat de droit.
Si l'on veut apprendre de lui,
il faut accepter l'échange
qui implique
la confrontation
des idées.
C'est sa position à lui.
Elle n'est pas la nôtre.
C'est celle qu'on condamne
dans notre système judiciaire.
C'est ce qui fait la vertu
de notre système judiciaire :
condamner les gens
après un débat.
Si on ne lui donne pas
la possibilité d'exprimer
sa position, on ne peut pas,
après, aller le chercher
dans ses contradictions.
Moi, je n'ai pas ressenti
de provocation de sa part.
Alors, peut-être
les premiers jours,
et encore, peut-on
parler de provocations ?
Il sortait
de 6 années d'isolement.
Il faut imaginer ce qu'est
l'isolement total.
L'absence de vie sociale,
l'absence de sexualité...
L'absence de lien
amical, familial,
ne pas pouvoir étreindre
ses proches.
Attention, je fais pas d'angélisme
et je ne le victimise pas.
J'essaye juste d'analyser
pourquoi ce garçon arrive
le premier jour
comme une bête en cage,
bah, moi, je crois que
c'est assez simple.
Il sort de 6 ans coupé du monde,
il arrive dans une salle d'audience
où tout le monde est
avec une attente...
Et puis une accusation publique,
extrêmement forte !
Il faut du temps...
D'ailleurs, il lui
a fallu du temps
pour s'apprivoiser,
pour revenir dans l'échange.
Ca s'est fait,
ça a choqué beaucoup de monde,
par le rire, qui a pu
être le leur,
dans le boxe.
Petit à petit,
il me semble
qu'il revient.
On n'a pas su y faire tout le temps.
Euh...
Peut-être que je suis
complètement naïve
et n'aurait-il
de toute façon pas accorder
sa parole.
Je reste convaincue
que si l'on...
Si on reste sur
un terrain d'humanité,
on y arrive.
On peut y arriver,
dans une certaine mesure.
-Certains vous ont reproché
votre empathie,
votre bienveillance,
à son égard,
ce qui revenait au fond
à vous blâmer d'avoir
instauré un dialogue
avec lui, et un lien.
On a également reproché
à l'accusé de ne dénier
répondre qu'à vous,
donc de choisir
son interlocutrice,
d'orienter
ses réponses
et se montrer plus humain,
d'être le maître
du jeu et de tirer
les ficelles.
-Je ne l'ai pas vécu
comme ça...
Je...
Alors...
Côté parties civiles,
on n'a pas tous,
nous, les avocats,
la même conception
du rôle qu'on doit jouer
dans l'audience.
Certains de mes confrères,
c'est leur position,
considèrent qu'on est
avocat en partie civile
pour corroborer
ce qu'on appelle
l'action publique.
Pour venir en soutien
de l'accusation,
du travail
des avocats généraux.
Dans certains procès,
peut-être.
A taille plus réduite.
Quand y a un vrai doute,
sur la culpabilité
des accusés,
quand on peut redouter
la reconnaissance
du préjudice de nos clients,
peut-être.
Dans les procès
de terrorisme, non.
L'accusation,
pour moi,
c'est ma conception
de mon rôle,
ce n'est pas de jouer
les procureurs bis.
Je sors de mon rôle d'avocat
dans ces procès-là.
Mon rôle est de...
De permettre à chaque victime
que j'accompagne de trouver
un intérêt dans ce procès.
Il n'est pas toujours le même.
Ils attendent pas la même chose.
Certains veulent
comprendre,
certains sont en colère,
certains veulent l'entendre,
les voir, leur parler...
Donc, moi, mon travail,
c'est d'accompagner cela,
d'accompagner
au cours des débats,
d'expliquer la façon
dont les débats
vont se passer,
et pour moi,
l'essentiel,
c'est de rentrer
en communication avec eux,
de parler,
de poser des questions.
Libre à eux de faire
ce qu'ils veulent.
Certains confrères considèrent
qu'il ne répondait pas
car il choisissait
ses interlocuteurs...
Eh bah, on va dire que oui,
il les a choisis, d'une façon.
Je n'y vois pas une perversité,
je n'y vois pas
une caractéristique
de manipulation.
Je ne vois pas cela,
en Salah Abdeslam.
Je suis pas psychiatre,
je suis pas psychologue,
c'est ma sensibilité,
mon voisin en aurait une autre.
Moi, je ne le crois pas.
Je pense que s'il accepte
de me répondre ou de répondre
à Aurélie Cerceau
ou quelques autres confrères,
c'est parce qu'il sent,
chez l'interlocuteur...
Il est pas idiot !
Il parle car il comprend
que ça peut se faire.
C'est aussi cela
que je regrette souvent
dans cette matière,
dans la matière
du terrorisme :
les actes sont
tellement monstrueux,
tellement effrayants...
La douleur est
tellement convoquée
qu'on règle trop
facilement les choses
de façon
manichéenne,
le bien contre le mal...
Il y a eu des plaidoiries,
"le bien contre le mal"...
"Forcément, si Salah Abdeslam parle,
"c'est pour dire des choses
mauvaises, des mensonges,
"des choses atroces."
Il ne pouvait rien
apporter à ce procès,
rien n'était acceptable
pour les parties civiles.
Moi, je ne le pense pas.
-Vous pensez
qu'il était inaudible ?
-Oui, pour beaucoup.
On peut pas le reprocher
aux victimes, évidemment !
C'est compliqué.
Il les a rendus dingues.
Il les a rendus dingues
dans le procès.
Un coup, il parle,
un coup, il parle pas.
Pour les victimes, c'est atroce.
D'ailleurs, ce jour,
où il arrive en disant
qu'il va pas parler
alors qu'on allait
aborder les faits,
du 13 novembre...
Euh...
Le président dit :
"C'était pas prévu."
Même lui est quand même
stupéfait de la position.
Je me tourne
vers la gauche
et je vois les victimes
dans la salle...
Il y avait une chape de plomb.
Le silence, c'est terrible.
C'est un mur insupportable.
Il fallait
le faire parler.
Et obtenir quelque chose.
Les semaines qui ont
précédé ce jour-là,
je le salue tous les jours
quand j'arrive à l'audience...
Je salue les autres.
On avait échangé au cours
de certains entretiens...
Il a compris que j'allais
pas le piéger.
Voilà...
-La peine prononcée
contre Salah Abdeslam,
la perpétuité
incompressible,
sanction la plus lourde
dans notre droit,
introduite en 1994,
vous semble-t-elle,
à la fois,
juste et justifiée ?
-C'est pas l'avocate
de parties civiles
qui répond,
mais l'avocate tout court.
Avant d'être avocat victime,
on est avocat tout court.
Et je suis par ailleurs
dans d'autres circonstances
avocate en défense,
donc je suis viscéralement
attachée aux droits humains.
-Certains de vos confrères y ont
vu la victoire du terrorisme...
Dans ce verdict.
-Pour moi, cette peine
ne devrait pas exister
dans le système.
Euh...
Elle est symbolique.
A l'évidence symbolique.
C'est un message adressé
au peuple,
une restitution.
Une restitution symbolique,
pour la nation et le peuple.
Finalement, tous les observateurs
extérieurs considéraient, bah...
Salah Abdeslam,
incarnant le mal absolu,
devait être
condamné au pire.
Il l'a été.
-Une peine de mort déguisée.
-C'est une peine de mort
déguisée.
Voilà.
Je crois que dans le système
judiciaire et carcéral,
on avait déjà tout
ce qui fallait
pour le garder en prison,
toute sa vie,
si c'est nécessaire.
Pour moi,
l'incompressibilité,
c'est un surplus
d'inhumanité,
qui, pour moi, ne fait pas honneur
à notre système judiciaire, car...
Ca doit être l'honneur
du système judiciaire,
de répondre au terrorisme.
Je suis fière de la justice.
Celle qui permet les débats,
qui permet l'échange contradictoire.
C'est exactement
ce qu'on combat,
quand on combat l'Etat islamique,
et les valeurs de l'Etat islamique.
On oppose à l'Etat islamique
une justice fantastique,
dont on se glorifie,
car on se glorifie
de ces procès...
Heureusement qu'ils se tiennent.
Je pense aux victimes accompagnées.
Mais répondre à l'inhumanité
par un surplus d'inhumanité,
ça ne m'apparaissait pas
nécessaire.
Salah Abdeslam a participé
à des actes monstrueux.
Il le sait.
Il ne s'en est pas caché.
Il l'a même revendiqué.
Il savait qu'il allait écoper
d'une peine extrêmement grave.
Il aurait pu être
condamné à perpétuité
avec 30 ans
de peine sureté.
Pas la peine d'en rajouter.
Oui, théoriquement,
il lui reste un espoir.
Dans 30 ans,
il pourra saisir
un tribunal d'application
des peines,
pour obtenir la fixation
d'une période de sûreté.
C'est un espoir digne
d'une feuille
de papier aluminium.
Voilà.
-Ce verdict n'est-il pas
une façon de répondre
la question que
beaucoup se posent :
un islamiste radicalisé
peut-il changer ?
Ce verdict revient à dire
qu'il n'y a pas de retour
possible pour certains.
-C'est ce que nous dit
ce verdict.
La peine est fixée en fonction
des possibilités de réadaptation.
Quand on prononce
une peine de perpétuité
incompressible,
c'est qu'on considère à l'issue
des 10 mois d'audience, qu'il est
foutu ! Et qu'il présente
aucun élément permettant
de penser qu'un jour,
il pourra évoluer.
Qu'on n'ait pas
envie d'y penser,
que le peuple n'ait
pas envie d'y penser,
ça, je le comprends,
c'est totalement humain.
Mais que des magistrats,
qui ont fait ce métier
toute leur vie,
prennent cette décision
ce jour-là,
moi, je n'y adhère pas,
et pourtant,
personne ne pourra
remettre en question
tout l'attachement
et l'amitié que je porte
à certaines victimes
que j'accompagne.
On a pleuré ensemble
pendant des années.
J'ai pleuré avec eux.
Je n'ai jamais autant serré
mes clients dans les bras.
Evidemment que quand je dis ça,
je ne vais pas
à l'encontre des victimes.
C'est même l'inverse.
Fondamentalement,
les victimes veulent
le retour à la sécurité,
le retour
à la sécurité antérieure,
et pour ça, il faut pas
perdre nos valeurs.
-Vous ne vous destiniez pas
à être avocate.
Vous avez commencé
par passer le prestigieux
concours de l'école Boulle,
avant de céder
à la pression familiale
et de passer le barreau.
Que s'est-il passé ?
-Le métier d'avocat n'est pas
venue après une déception,
car je n'ai pas pu embrasser
une carrière artistique.
J'y ai pensé,
même, très petite.
J'étais fan d'une série pas glamour,
et peu de gens s'en souviennent...
Moi, je regardais
"Perry Mason"...
Perry Mason,
c'est celui,
justement,
qui vient casser
les certitudes !
Je suis venue au métier d'avocat
par Perry Mason...
Rires
J'avais,
de toute façon,
cette inspiration,
et puis j'ai toujours été
fascinée par le phénomène criminel
et par le besoin de comprendre
ce qui amène un être humain
à passer à l'acte.
J'avais par ailleurs
des aspirations
artistiques très fortes.
Attention.
J'ai pas passé
le concours de Boulle.
J'ai passé en cachette
un petit examen
pour rentrer à l'école
et j'ai été très faible.
Mon père a dit non.
C'était un non sans appel.
A l'époque,
j'étais pas suffisamment
costaud et solide pour dire :
"Je ferai ce que je veux."
J'ai fait des études de droit
et ce qui devait
se passer s'est passé.
J'ai mis de côté
la profession d'avocat
et j'ai travaillé
la mosaïque...
-A la mort de votre mère,
vous quittez la robe,
pour vivre 1000 vies.
Un nombre de métiers...
Cheffe cuisinière,
fondeur d'or, mosaïste...
Vous avez travaillé chez
une mosaïste italienne.
Vous avez été
hôtesse de l'air.
Vous avez pensé vous
lancer en politique.
Elles rient.
-Oui, j'ai...
Je...
Bah, de toute façon,
voilà,
si on suit beaucoup trop
les prescriptions parentales,
voilà ce qui se passe.
-On se rue
dans les brancards.
-Nécessairement.
Je n'en veux pas
non plus à mon père
car j'exerce aujourd'hui
un métier,
vraiment,
que j'adore.
Je suis passionnée
par mon métier,
j'adore mon métier d'avocat,
et je n'ai aucune difficulté
à passer de la défense d'une victime
à la défense pénale d'un accusé.
Je suis passionnée
par mon métier.
-Vous vous dites heureuse
de plaider pour des valeurs
que vous partagez.
Vous défendez
Terre des femmes, engagée
contre les violences sexistes,
que Greenpeace, qui lutte
pour la survie de la planète.
Des causes nobles.
Un luxe inouï.
-Je n'ai que de la chance.
Je suis une avocate chanceuse.
Je...
C'est pas donné
à tout le monde
mais tous les matins,
je me lève pour faire
ce que j'aime.
-Vous défendriez
un violeur d'enfants
ou un terroriste islamiste ?
-Un terroriste islamiste,
oui, j'aurais pu.
Maintenant,
c'est plus compliqué.
J'interviens depuis
un certain nombre d'années
pour des victimes d'attentats,
pour l'Association
française des victimes
du terrorisme, donc,
ça pourrait me placer dans
un conflit d'intérêt.
Je serais certainement amenée à dire
non, mais non pas pour des questions
de principe personnel,
j'aurais pu défendre
des terroristes islamistes,
mais je ne le ferai pas,
pour des raisons déontologiques.
-Le Graal serait de rejoindre
la cour pénale internationale,
chargée de juger
les génocides,
crimes de guerre
et contre l'humanité.
Que du léger.
-Que du léger,
mais parce que...
Je vais vous dire
sincèrement les choses.
Après le V13,
on est allés loin,
et j'ai pas envie
de repartir en arrière
sur des procès qui
m'intéresseraient moins.
J'ai maintenant...
Bon, j'ai 50 ans
et j'ai des attentes
intellectuelles...
Je veux continuer à passer
ces journées palpitantes !
J'aime aussi le lien entre
mon métier et l'actualité,
de mon pays.
Avec la CPI, je voudrais
qu'il y ait un lien
entre mon métier
et l'actualité du monde
dans lequel je vis.
Dans ma candidature,
il y avait
des cases à cocher :
"Préférez-vous défendre
des accusés ou des victimes ?"
Moi, j'ai coché la case
"Pas de préférence".
Voilà, je continuerai
à défendre des personnes
accusées de meurtre,
d'assassinat...
Je vais bientôt plaider
un dossier de viol.
Pour moi, y a pas de camp à choisir.
Je pense même que
ça peut être la force
d'un avocat de pouvoir plaider
en partie civile et côté accusé,
parce qu'on connaît les 2 parties,
et pour moi, tout ce qui est...
-C'est une richesse.
-Oui.
Oui, oui.
Finalement, j'ai pas fait
de politique pour ça.
Pour moi, ça n'a pas de sens
d'être "tanké" dans un camp.
En revanche,
faire un lien,
entre nos valeurs morales,
nos convictions d'avocat,
notre passion de défendre,
et avoir la chance
qui est la mienne,
de pouvoir plaider dans
des dossiers qui font
le lien avec le monde
dans lequel je vis,
c'est un luxe inouï.
-Comment êtes-vous
sortie
de cette "cathédrale
de la douleur",
pour reprendre les mots
de Sylvie Caster ?
Au terme de ces 10 mois
de procès du V13.
-Alors,
après le procès V13...
"Cathédrale de douleur"...
Alors...
C'est compliqué
pour les professionnels
mais attention, on est...
On la met pas au même niveau
que celle des victimes,
évidemment, mais oui,
c'est quelque chose qui
nous a tellement occupé,
pris aux tripes...
Les procès d'assises,
c'est tellement addictif.
On les vit intensément.
Oui, il y a eu un "down", derrière.
Ce n'est pas simple.
C'est rassurant,
quand vient le congé
en septembre car tous
les professionnels
qu'on croise,
personne ne va bien,
avocats, magistrats,
journalistes,
on est tous un peu
en post-trauma
et ça nous plonge
dans des états inédits.
Les assises,
ça fait toujours ça.
Quand on en sort,
il faut se remettre
dans le monde.
Là, ça a été 10 mois.
On s'y remet en reprenant
la vie quotidienne,
et puis on passe
à d'autres procès.
Il faut pas non plus laisser
tomber les victimes,
car il y a le temps long,
le procès règle pas tout.
Il faut continuer
à accompagner.
On fait comme d'habitude.
On essaye d'être
sur tous les fronts.
-Merci, Claire.
-Merci à vous.
-Merci infiniment.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...